okay so I don't want to talk about what
I'm about to talk about that doesn't
really make sense right but I do want to
talk about it in the sense of telling
you not to pay attention to it and the
only way to tell you not to talk about
it is by talking about it does that make
any sense what the hell am I talking
about I'm talking about a new CNN poll
that says Trump is losing to Bernie
Sanders that Trump is losing to Joe
Biden and Trump is losing to Oprah
Winfrey in hypothetical 2020
presidential matchups the polling like a
lot of CNN's polling was done by SSRS
and it did a bunch of these imaginary
20/20 general election matchups that
assume Trump will be the Republican
nominee and if you interpret the poll
literally it seems like things are just
going so well for everyone but Trump
look at some of the matchups that the
poll asked voters about they said if it
was Trump vs. Bernie Sanders who would
you vote for Bernie comes out ahead 55
to 42 crushing Trump if it was Joe Biden
versus Donald Trump who would you vote
for 57 to 40 Joe Biden ahead and if it
was Oprah against Trump who would you
vote for according to the poll of
registered voters taken this month 51 to
42 Oprah would defeat Donald Trump now
there are a ton of internals we could
look at and slice and dice the data but
I don't want to because my message to
you is this don't pay attention to this
crap don't worry about 2020 right now
number one there are midterm elections
in nine months that could determine the
future of the presidency the future of
health care the future of net neutrality
which we're going to talk about with
Craig Aaron today the future of how we
deal with climate change to even start
thinking about whether Oprah or Joe are
better candidates for 2020 and right now
before the 2018 midterms before robert
molars Trump Russia investigation really
gives us more definition on what took
place this is a recipe for losing that's
number one but even worse is seeing the
numbers and thinking oh whoever runs
again
Trump is going to crush it and I don't
even need to be engaged politically or
worry about 2018 or 2020 this is a
recipe for disaster and it's one of
these weird things Pat because I don't
want to give attention to 2020 polling
right but at the same time this poll is
getting so much traction and being
posted so much online that I do want to
get out ahead of it and say don't if
Oprah Winfrey would defeat Donald Trump
in November of 2020 based on January
2018 polling it should have no impact
whatsoever on our political activism for
the next nine months and for the next
three years
yeah we got to get through the midterms
and even after that maybe summer of 2019
we can start talking about 2020 and
that's crazy because that's more than a
year out of the election it's almost
late my recent stand that's crazy
yeah it's absolutely insane let me put
it to you a different way though because
maybe I want to be open since we're
talking about it let me at least explore
a different position can you think of
anything good that comes from focusing
on a poll like this in January of 2018
like is now okay you're the king of
finding bizarre silver linings just to
make ourselves feel like marginally
better is there any that you can find in
this I think it minimizes the importance
of policy if we just focus on the horse
race yeah I mean this has been going on
since the day after Donald Trump won the
election that's awesome about 2020 will
Hillary want to run again will Joe Biden
run again or Bernie Sanders yeah and we
got to get beyond that I think I I tend
to agree and I just can't think of
anything that we stand to gain by saying
well Joe's polling 57% in Oprah's 51 so
therefore so therefore what right at the
January of 2018 what difference does it
make and by the way we're talking two of
those three people are gonna be close to
80 years old at the time 2020 election
and not to be ageist but I do think that
there is something to consider in terms
of whether the Democratic Party wants to
be the primary of nearly 80 year old
white dudes I don't know I'm just
throwing the question out there but I
don't think we should say more about it
okay
well I'll say one more thing okay I
think people who are fans of Oprah are
picking that out and saying see Oprah
would crush Trump yeah
probably ignoring the fact that Biden or
Sanders would perform better yeah all
right that that's I we've discussed we
don't I've told you why I think we
shouldn't focus on this and if you have
more to say about it by all means join
us on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t after the break we
will welcome back it's been a while
since he's been on CEO of free press
Craig Aaron not Aaron Craig he's not
Aaron Craig he's Craig Aaron and he
doesn't like it when people mix that up
he'll join me next if you've been
hearing about Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
and you want to get involved maybe by a
little but you just don't know how coin
base is for you coin base is the world's
most used way to buy sell and use
Bitcoin etherium litecoin and Bitcoin
cash if you sign up through david
pakman.com slash coinbase
and buy or transfer $100 worth of
Bitcoin you'll get a $10 bonus and so
will we
so you'll be supporting the David Pakman
show sign up today at david pakman.com
slash coinbase